>> Today,
I'm talking with Grahame Grieve,
the project leader of the global
HL7 FHIR standardization effort.
He's here all the way from Melbourne,
Australia for
an HL7 meeting this week in Atlanta.
Grahame, thank you very much for
taking the time to be with me.
I know this is a busy week for
you, perhaps we could begin by
discussing your background.
>> So I qualified as a biochemist,
worked in a clinical lab and
did a bit of research, and then I ended
up as a lab systems vendor tech lead and
got more involved in
interoperability in HL7.
And eventually, created my own
consulting company to do HL7 consulting.
>> So beginning in 2011,
you invented the whole idea of FHIR.
Can you tell us how that happened?
>> We were getting to a point
where the HL7 was at a crossroads.
We had a lot of existing standards that
no longer reflected what people wanted
to do and there was a lot of
unhappiness in the music community.
And we said, well,
what if we do something like this, and
that grew into FHIR.
It was a bit of a surprise to me as
much as to everyone else that it was so
popular, but it's been certainly
keeping busy ever since.
>> By all accounts, the growth of FHIR
adoption is nothing short of phenomenal.
Could you give us an idea of how it's
being adopted not just here in the US,
but around the world?
>> Well, we expected that initially
while it's still a trial beta standard,
which it still is, that we would
have a little bit of adoption,
particularly in companies doing health
data exchange in the social web area,
but it's just been crazy.
We have government programs, large
government programs, some ONC programs.
Other national governments around
the world that have big vendors
creating consortiums like Argonaut and
HSBC, lots of little companies,
and institutions creating
solutions based on FHIR.
We have thousands of implementations
happening at the moment.
>> So I believe the ballot on FHIR as
a second version of a draft standard for
trial use was just conducted or
is being conducted.
Where are we in the whole evolution
of FHIR to a full HL7 standard?
>> So we had balanced it
to standard in May, and
then we just published last week in
September, the formal second version.
It's an ongoing process where we
started with a very initial draft and
then I think of this as
the first fully usable version.
And we're calling it a trial version, so
we can still introduce new content and
refine the core standard.
But increasingly, we're going to treat
the core as a normative standard and
I think the next version will
represent a stable version for
implementors to base
the core clinical stuff on.
But it's an ongoing process and
we'll be very driven by the feedback
we get from the community about that,
which is why we're not saying
right now how it will unfold.
We don't want to dictate
to the community.
>> Well, I've heard numbers in terms of
the ultimate number of FHIR resources
anywhere from 100 to 200.
I suppose nobody actually
knows at this point.
>> Well, we have 96 as of today.
And we sort of said,
200 was a nice number.
We didn't want to have thousands or
hundreds of thousands,
which were possible choices.
We haven't got a fixed number
that we're going to get to.
>> So
that leads directly to a topic you and
I have discussed when we
were together in the past.
To me, the whole, I mean, obviously, the
use of web services and JSON objects,
these technologies are so common in
other domains is very interesting and
I think very important
to the success of FHIR.
But perhaps even more interesting
is your mission of not allowing
FHIR to become an overly
complex standard like many of
the predecessor standards in HL7.
How is that going?
That must be a very tough thing to do.
>> It's an interesting thing to try and
do.
We have constant pressures to try and
simplify it, and
constant pressures to try and
complicate it.
And we've gotta strike a balance between
handling the things people need to do,
and not letting it get so complicated
no one can do what they need to do.
Most of the success in that area
comes from the processes that
we laid down at the start
around soul of engagement with
the implementation community and
being responsive to them.
And we grade the success of parts of
the standard not by publication, but
by adoption, and that's a very
important metric that drives a wider
consideration of the perspective than
just how do we produce a standard.
>> So, the people who only
have to use the standard and
implement it have a big voice
in what the standard looks like.
And it isn't just designed by,
I'll use the term standards geeks.
I hope that isn't a pejorative term.
>> That's a very common term.
That's exactly what we're
trying to achieve, so
that you can define
the standard as a committee.
But until it's been adopted and
proven in practice,
it's always going to be draft.
>> So as you look out toward
the future after the final version of
FHIR is published, how do you
see it continuing to evolve and
adapt to an ever changing world?
>> Any community goes through the phases
of storming, norming and conforming.
And clearly, the core of
the specification is moving into
the norming phase now and
will become more and more stable and
growth will happen at the margins.
And then there's at some
point where you'll say
that the standard is now
got as big as it can be.
It's no longer efficient to keep growing
and to keep pushing it along, and
it's time to start
considering a new choice.
I kind of thought, just looking
at the past record of standards
that a development lifespan
might be 15 years or so.
I mean, it's sort of 5 of 15 now.
And then at that point,
you start to say maybe it's no
longer worth keeping going.
That's ten years out,
we'll see how we go.
But at some point, you go,
it's just not worth keeping going.
>> So, one final question.
So what would you say to the students
taking this course about FHIR and
about how they might both think
about it, use it, and look for
opportunities that FHIR creates?
>> FHIR's really different to all
the other approaches we've had,
because it allows you to
modularize your solutions and
to create capabilities that can be
used in all sorts of different ways.
And so in the long-term it's
going to represent decomposing large
systems into more interruptible
small systems and there's going to
be a lot of opportunity for
change in the healthcare system not IT,
but in healthcare itself driven by the
capabilities of the decomposition and
the flexibility that it offers.
We didn't write FHIR because we
wanted to have a nice standard.
We wrote FHIR because we wanted
implementations to drive a better
healthcare system.
And that's going to be our main focus
going forwards is we'll round out
the standard and finalize the standard,
but our main focus is going to
be how do we drive that to get
a healthcare system that's more nimble,
more patient focused,
more responsive to it to change,
because the existing
system's pretty rigid.
>> Well, I not only want to thank you,
I want to tell you how much I
admire you and what you're doing.
I'm a lot older than you are.
I'm not even sure you were born when
I got involved in health IT, and
I never thought I'd actually
live to see what we're seeing,
which I agree with you completely is
an absolutely workable, implementable,
deployable solution to
interoperability and
to actually making health data
a tool for improving healthcare.
So, congratulations.
Thank you so much.
>> Thanks.